wir werden uns um ein paar bilder
angucken er sind welche stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
stopp meines aufenthalts willkommen zu
einem neuen video max sitzt neben mir
das heißt es gibt heute eine folge von
als tv classics und heute an werden
wieder am start das für uns beide
persönlich sehr wichtig ist das video
liegt uns beide sehr nah am herzen denn
das hat uns und den einstieg in asse tv
gegeben damals normalerweise mache ich
das ja immer so dass ihr uns vorschläge
gemacht und wir den meisten kommentaren
ihm auch diesmal uns gedacht wir nehmen
uns mal das recht heraus persönlichen
vorschlag einzubringen das ist wie
gesagt ein persönliches alle von uns
leute und wir legen direkt los 17 jahre
alt und hatte auch schon mehrere
anzeigen wegen körperverletzungen
herzlich willkommen
[Applaus]
dass hier leute in zu gehen ein bisschen
schlechter qualität weil das video schon
arsch alt ist ein mega schwer zu finden
war ist erst wieder type r so der
prototyp von so einem jungen typen der
sich für ein bisschen zu gangsta hält
[Applaus]
ihr müsst wissen ich glaube die show
gibt es gar nicht mehr das war glaube
ich oliver geissen und das ist dann
immer so eine talkrunde also sitzen
verschiedene menschen zusammen der runde
unterhalten sich und die menschen sind
oft verschieden damit man irgendwie so
eine kleine debatte auslösen
ihr könnt euch vorstellen wie er sie
sich verhält in seiner diskussion
was ist bei dir los würdest du dein
leben schreiben läuft das alles so wird
es hier vorstellt oder gab es ja schon
mal eine kleine abzweigung ja du hast
alles gute auf der straße werde ich dich
an läuft alles gut hier auf der straße
ist jetzt gerade in so übertrieben teure
studie so besser ist wenn du so willst
dann ist das zu betonen musste dass auf
der straße gut läuft
17 und rapper aus hagen
das würde mich echt interessieren ob
leute von ob ihr das auch kennt weil auf
youtube gibt es das glaube ich schon gar
nicht mehr das heißt ihr seid quasi
exklusiv gerade bei dem video quatsch
was machst du auf der straße als das
straßenbild ja strafen straßen geld
begeisterte video das geht so weit dass
oliver großen jetzt nicht etwas straßen
gilt der macht auch selbst auch locker
strafen geht und was ist straßen
eigentlich wieder größer
es läuft gut auf der straße ja aber was
du etwas machst du auf der straße geht
das beginnt straßen geldstrafen gehen
dieses jahr vergessen
ach ja richtig geile gab ich diese
eigenartigen dritte das ist halt
wirklich so 2009 2018 oder sogar so
richtig empfinde das hobby reporter ab
sein geld machen oder nicht
jetzt sehen wir was wir strafen gegen
cash machen auf der straße
der change einfach chef peter kellner
interview mit so einem bauunternehmer
also sie haben ja auch die neue autobahn
die a38 gebaut was ist ein
geschäftsmodell cash woche auf der
straße erstochen auf der straße ja
welche machst du das was machst du da ja
ja sag doch mal konkret was konkret wie
machst du das reduziert das mittelalter
ist eine richtige ahlmann frau und er
seien der die sofort gegessen was aber
sie sagt ja morgen war zeigt nochmal
konkret natürlich wird er sehen jetzt
nicht seine recherche auf der straße
markiert also natürlich nicht mehr
jedoch nach macht die macht dann auch
noch die zieht aber auch leute aber auf
der straße auf der straße also sagen die
die nicht legal sind
hellwig arbeite damit stellt er dem das
egal
natürlich sachen die nicht legal sind
warum fragt er noch so dumm
okay die masse da ja und dann davon
davon lebte im augenblick oder japan
das geht ewig so weiter oder man es
natürlich irgendwann mal kriegen geht
noch weiter er war seit langem als
optimist könnte sein also du machst ja
öfter so illegale sachen denkst du
irgendwann wirst du mal erwischt
er hat auch manchmal selbst herrnburger
was geht immer weiter der kann das noch
gut einschätzen 17
na ja das ist schon eine perspektive die
leute wissen ja nicht was machen sie
nach dem abi
weiß dass er sein leben lang auf der
straße geld passstraßen dass keine angst
davor dass ich irgendwann dass ich
irgendwann packen und dass sie dann weg
bis wert nicht denn obwohl ich spüre sie
nennen würde das die polizei wie du sind
dann würdest unterstellte erstmal die
stimme
obwohl ihn formal spüren sie nennen
würde das die polizei ja ich kann ja
nichts machen so war muss damit ich
meine was wollen die gegen den
17-jährigen aussagen machen
das soll die deutschlands polizei gegen
den machen geht nicht der wenn alles
klappt das nicht immer weiter man kann
ja nicht machen die kammern kommen
können nichts machen
ja ich mich und diese frist setzen würde
warum finden sie dass sie jetzt nicht
des raubes verurteilt werden sollten die
sind ja wegen rauf angeklagt ja ich bin
chef von teuren sie mich nicht die
staatsanwaltschaft die anklage zurück
ich bin ja gab es schon mal ärger mit
der polizei wegen körperverletzung kann
ich schon erzählt oft ja fast gemacht so
viele der zitate diesen so bei uns
verankert fast können ist also sowas
geht aber die post schlagen weiß was das
nächste mal kommt die herzen kommt
wer erst geschlagen ja paar deutschen
ehepaar deutschen avr deutsch-deutschen
muss sich das mal extra dazu sag ich
doch schon gesagt fast geschlagen ohne
wird wir sind zwar beide deutsch aber
ich fühle mich zu hundert prozent nicht
angegriffen durch ersehen uns aussage
weil es einfach da wird er seinen chef
da kann keiner was machen was man was
willst du machen die polizei
deutsch-deutsche geschlagen warum gab
ein grund dafür bis zu angegriffen
worden
ergreift mich das schon gucken aber da
kommt da kam der rapper durch da kam der
apple ii greife ich denke ich war black
alt kräftig schon prima an der sie dazu
diesen stil so busch
2001 hieß es weiter wahrscheinlich ist
es wirklich 2001 herta müller genauso
aus er gab den dank einer person also ok
also tun hat die angriff warum hast du
den angeklagten vater los ja weil die
geld hatten und deswegen hat er sich
angegriffen
ja es stimmt wir verlängern man muss
doch er hat einfach schon einplanen
geben als auch ein grund warum man das
tier angegriffen oder die geld hatten
pure super etwas das findet begründung
weil die geld hatten ja dann ja normal
ja ich mal was bringt das wenn leute an
geldern normal ja nicht mal gesagt dass
die ausraubt und die haut die einfach
mal geld dann bist du bist reicht das
geld alles klappt wir werden uns von dir
ein paar bilder angucken er sich
[Musik]
ok stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp stopp
stopp stopp stopp stopp moment catalent
wenn die polizei das sieht richtig die
können nichts machen oder aber die
werden schon hat er hat eine mögliche
täter oder getreten
also deshalb will ich der zeitpunkt ok
bisher war es lustig so ich habe gesagt
ja dem jahr lang deutsche zuschlag
deutsche so raubtier aus und mir egal
aber eine mülltonne zu treten auch noch
auf kanadas ist eine ordnungswidrigkeit
also ganz ehrlich ich glaube ich
wünschte die polizei konnte da was
machen und was die machen so abgeräumt
wird die beliebte also über so schon ein
bisschen gesagt von gar keine fraktur am
busbahnhof in der neuen stadt fragt zu
irgendeinem typen dahin erstattet 90
euro kommentiert zum vom kölner dom
er will so antworten ja gesagt lange
stück das da kannst du dich nicht mit
irgendwelchen alle begeistert auch
übertrieben wirkt das ist ja nicht
draufgehauen hat ja eine ausnahme
gemacht wer fernsehen echt zurück
richtig wichtiger trigger emsland stop
stop die ampel leute guckt mal ganz
genau auf die ampel das passiert in
unserem land leute es reicht menschen
treten mülleimer und gehen dann noch
über roth möchte von allen guten
geistern verlassen aber ist auch geil
der hat zu diesen dank von diesen ganzen
dingen die sie zur havel wo diese waren
gegen so denkst du dass du nicht nur für
die wirbelsäule richard clarke direkt
wieder abschieben und in seinem land
ausgeschieden oder abnehmen kann doch
keiner kommenden jahr soll eine kräftige
frau publikum abschied mutter abnehmen
ja es gibt ihn böse erreger dass er
besser leben in der schule aber so ok ok
nehmen wie du bist so was in deinem land
würde man sich schon längst einsperren
und sehe ich das nicht
schirme auf aldi das war es einfach die
frau dass sie ihr leben ist vorbei was
er davor gesagt na ja gesagt wenn man
rückwärts nicht wieso erwarte dafür
braucht eine minute darauf an die firma
fitness experte werner kommen wir zur
bewertung heute haben wir die faktoren
spaßfaktor sprüche menschen gesehen es
nämlich abstoßen faktor und legenden
status spaßfaktor 7 von 10 7 von 10
finde ich auch wo der sprüche oh ja ich
jetzt schon gut ist brüche sind gut aber
es sind nicht so viele die sind hoch
qualitativen aber abschieben oder
abnehmen sodass schon jetzt widmen also
ich würde sagen acht von zehn oder ich
werde 7 geben echt ja sagen wir sie mal
menschlich gesehen ziemlich abstoßend
faktor 10 von 10 19 volle kanne tee
gramm also vier abstoßen geht nicht
jetzt sollte zur finalen kategorie
legendenstatus also ich finde er sind
leiden darunter dass es jetzt schon so
alt ist also schon echt relativ alt und
dementsprechend würde ich auch immer 7
geben hier ja 77 krieg gut damit kommen
wir ins gesamt noch eine punktzahl von
31,5 von 40 was ihr so machen können
heute ist einmal den kommentaren die
essentielle frage des lebens beantworten
abschieben oder abnehmen und hier drüben
die adtv classics playlist abchecken mit
den folgen von nadine und andreas
schreibt mikrometer aber was jetzt nicht
sehen wollte und bis zum nächsten video